Close your eyes
See with mind
You are a top student, but look at you now
You can't keep using your father's disappearance as an excuse to act out
Is that his work?
What's is about?
Her dad wanted to
touch the stars
Imagine that the
ant here wants to get to her other hand
It's quickest option is to walk across the string
But it turns out,
a straight line is not the shortest distance between two points
Not if you use a fifth dimension
It's outside of the rules we know of time and space
So, the ant arrives in my hand instantaneously
So you fold space?
More like we wrinkle it.
Where are we?
We heard a cry out in the universe
My father's alive
We believe he is
and we're here to help you find him
We are in search of warriors
Warriors to serve the good and the light and the universe
You're kidding
Do I look like I'm kidding?
A little
I'm not
Your father is trapped by evil energy
It's too strong for our light
And the only one who can stop it
Is you
Be a warrior
My love is always there
even if you can't see
Do you trust me?
I trust you
Meg